Arthur wanted to investigate how the
amount of exercise he does affects his
weight each week he recorded the number
of hours he exercised during the past
week and the change in his weight during
that week positive mean positive number
means he gained weight negative number
or negative means he lost weight
suppose Arthur wants to create a
scatterplot according to the data
presented below complete the sentences
below the amount of exercise should go
on thee well we want to put we want to
put the driving variable on the
horizontal axis and the dependent
variable on the vertical axis so the
amount of exercise is what drives or
what in theory drives his weight gain or
weight loss so we would want to put the
exercise the thing that's driving the
other variable or what that or that
might be driving the other variable that
we want to investigate whether it's
driving the other variable we want to
put that on the horizontal axis the
range of that axis should be from well
we just have to see what's his range of
exercise over this investigation he's
doing so let's see his largest amount of
exercise that he performs in hours is
let's see this 8.9 here that looks like
the largest amount of exercise he
performs and what's the least the
smallest amount of exercise he performs
looks like it's zero zero point three is
the smallest amount of exercise and so
we would want it to be from zero point
three or I guess we could go from zero
all the way to well we eight won't be
good enough because we have a couple of
data points that are at eight eight
point four eight point nine we need to
go all the way to ten we definitely
don't have to go we don't have to go
negative because we're not there's no
negative amount of exercise here so zero
to ten should be sufficient